but that's amazing no that's something I
don't that we don't think about a lot is
like instead of just looking at the
world why don't you clean the weapon
that you're looking at the world with
you you got it cuz people think of it
this way Theo people don't experience
life they experience the life they focus
on right so right now there's a if
you're happy you are deleting all the
things you could be pissed off about or
frustrated or worried about in the world
if you're unhappy you're deleting all
the things that are great in your life
Wow and our brains delete and they
distort and they generalize so if you
don't
direct it you get whatever shows up
what's wrong is always available what's
wrong in the world it's always available
what's right is also available it's just
which one you pick and it isn't about
positive thinking because I I've never
been into positive thinking people think
I that's what I do it's not I believe in
intelligence and so when you're in a
lousy State of Mind you treat people
poorly you don't perform at the highest
level you're not happy when you're in a
great state of mind you treat people
better perform at a different place and
it's one of the reasons the humor is so
valuable it changes People's State and
then you know all of a sudden they're in
a different place respond in a different
place when they're laughing them when
they're pissed off yeah so why not train
yourself to do that you've trained
yourself to find what's entertaining or
funny and just about anything is what
makes you as good as you are in that
area you have developed patterns of how
to do it you may not even be conscious
of them all and this this goes right
into something I was thinking about
since it's like the new year you know
and happy New Year to you and um and
yeah CU people so often say like New
Year's resolution and they're like but
that doesn't really that's kind of like
a oneand done it feels almost outdated
that idea but how do you CH I guess and
you just kind of answered I guess like
how we change our perspective so like so
we change our attitude you know that's
really what you need to have a new
experience yeah you there's three
decisions you're making every moment
your life your audience can test this
out the first one is what are you going
to focus on now when I say make these
decisions Theo I don't mean you're
making them all consciously right so
whatever you focus on that's what you
feel if you're supposed to meet your
boyfriend girlfriend husband wife
whoever at 7 o'clock you get there at
7even they're not there some people are
pissed off some people are worried it's
the same event if it's 7:30 and they're
not there they've not called they not
text now what are you feeling some
people go I'm really pissed off I'm
really worried I'm really single you
know really single I'm it's 8:30 I
haven't showed up I'm full I didn't wait
for the bastard you know but the point
is whether you're angry or whether you
were worried had nothing to do with the
event it's the habits of your mind the
person who's worried thinks oh maybe
they're in a car accent person's pissed
off they did it again so the first
decision you make is what are you going
to focus on and most people have
patterns of focus so there's three I'll
give you your audience can test out do
you tend to focus more on what you have
or what's missing what's missing yeah do
you tend to focus more on what you can
control or what you can't
control probably what I can't control
because but it's out of desperation
because I feel like I have to control
everything well that's not a bad thing
you can't control everything right it's
an illusion but you can influence so
much you can control everything in you
okay and then the third one do you tend
to tend focus more on the past the
present or the future the past yeah so
so those three patterns if you do all
three of them if you constantly look at
what's missing it's hard to ever stay
fulfilled or happy yeah so you have to
always do something to try to make
yourself happy because you're always
noticing what's missing that's just
where your focus goes there's always
something missing there's always
something that's not missing there's
always something beautiful if you focus
on what you have you're going to be more
fulfilled second one if you focus on
what you can control what you do it's
why you have your own business is why
who you are but a lot of people focus on
what they can't control it's
overwhelming they're stressed out they
think of all those things so if you
constantly focus on What's Missing You
can't control and the past which you
can't change what that makes is either
angry or sad or frustrated or depressed
yeah instead of just being like I want
to have this New Year's resolution
another rule for myself I need to change
the ruler that's you got it you got it's
like I need to that's what I need to
change but a lot of people times we
don't even see that we're the ruler yeah
a great a great metaphor you know you
know like if you wanted to go to a I
don't know if you're into racing at all
but like a Lon a 24-hour race or Baja
1000 you could have a amazing car
Ferrari mer it's not going to last you
have to re-engineer that car to be able
to take on the desert or drive for 24
hours or go to the ones that are in the
desert there where they have a pipe so
that when you go down it still can get
the air to the combustion of the engine
we have to re-engineer ourselves so the
times
in